es gibt hier weiter mit dem nächsten
punkt top 30
fluggast sicherheit ein antrag der cdu
csu bundestagsfraktion fluggastrechte
weiterentwickeln und
der as redner ist ingmar jung von der
cdu/csu herr präsident meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren wir stehen
vor der sommerzeit für viele die
schönste zeit des jahres die zeit mit
der familie urlaub zu machen die zeit
mal bis runter zu kommen die zeit etwas
erholung zu genießen und auch wir stehen
vor der parlamentarischen sommerpause
aber uns stets vielleicht noch nicht
ganz so zu wie anderen aber wir wollen
nach einem schwierigen halbjahr ist doch
wirklich den menschen in deutschland
können jetzt erholung genießen zu können
und auch mal in die ferien zu fahren
aber für viele steht vor sommer sonne
strand meer erst mal ein großes
abenteuer nämlich das abenteuer
flughafen und das hat sich in diesem
jahr noch deutlich verschärft täglich
bekommen wir meldungen über rekord
warteschlangen über wartezeiten über
annulierte flüge über umbuchung und über
gestrandete menschen übrigens auch in
den bahnhöfen und ja das vielen es
verleitet wird den urlaub irgendwie zu
genießen ich finde da besteht doch
deutlicher handlungsbedarf wenn sie sich
anschauen die letzten aktuellen zahlen
die wir haben im jahr 2020 allein 4000
meldungen von verstößen gegen die
fluggastrechte-verordnung sechseinhalb
1000 schlichtungsverfahren alles doppelt
so viel wie im jahr 2019 und das sind im
jahr 2020 in dem der flugverkehr massiv
eingeschränkt war und teilweise hat man
das gefühl dass das auch in der branche
einfach so hingenommen wird und ich
finde das ist ein zustand der im jahr
2022 wirklich nicht hinnehmbar ist mein
amt an es geht uns nicht darum dass wir
flugunternehmen vorschreiben wollen wie
sie ihre arbeit machen dass wir
vorschreiben wollen dass es nicht mehr
passieren kann dass ein flug ausfällt
dass man eine verspätung gibt oder
ähnliches aber was wir wirklich
erreichen müssen im jahr 2000 21 das
wenigstens ordentliche transparenz
hergestellt wird und dass die
verbraucher die letztlich kosten dafür
zahlen die dafür zahlen in urlaub
fliegen zu können die schäden hinnehmen
müssen am ende auch zu ihren rechten
kommen und deswegen wollen wir
wollen wir ganz konkret vier dinge
festlegen
das flugunternehmen
wenigstens verpflichtet werden mal
öffentlich zu erklären welche
verspätungen es gibt welche
ausgleichzahlungen am ende auch
vorgenommen werden dass verbraucher die
einen schaden hinnehmen müssen umgehend
darüber informiert werden wenn
überbuchungen stattfinden wenn
annullierungen stattfinden wenn
verspätungen stattfinden das sie
übrigens sich dann auch nicht durch ein
formular zunge kämpfen müssen sondern
dass zur verfügung gestellt bekommen
damit sie ihre rechte durchsetzen können
und das auch die zivilrechtlichen
durchsetzbarkeit vereinfacht für
vereinfacht wird zum beispiel im wege
von sogenannten smart contracts die
automatisch im falle des schadens am
ende die erstattung gewährleisten und
nicht am ende der der seinen urlaub
nicht genießen konnte der später weg kam
der gar nicht weg kamen dann noch
monatelang in irgendwelchen verfahren
seinen berechtigten anspruch nach rennen
muss das sollten wir wirklich schaffen
und als vierten punkt sollten wir es
noch hinbekommen dass wir auch eine
europäische insolvenzsicherung haben für
die die im vorfeld ein flug bezahlen im
ein ende nicht antreten können dass die
nicht auf den kosten sitzen bleiben
sondern längst dort eine erstattung
bekommen und wenn wir dann gemeinsam
hinkriegen dass man sich vielleicht
wieder etwas mehr auf die schöne
sommerzeit frei freuen kann in
deutschland haben wir schon viel
erreicht aber die schönste zeit des
jahres auch wieder für die menschen in
deutschland die schönste zeit des jahres
herzlichen dank vielen dank herr kollege
jungen bevor ich die nächsten rennen das
wort erteilen will ich darauf hinweisen
dass die zeit zur namentlichen
abstimmung sich dem ende nähert also
werden auch im saal auf den fluren oder
in die büros nicht abgestimmt hat an die
urne
nächste rednerin ist die kollegin dr
sondern martins spd-fraktion
präsident liebe kolleginnen der
demokratischen parteien werte
verbraucherinnen und fluggäste an
deutschen flughäfen hast gerade wirklich
keine urlaubslaune sondern frust und
ärger für die fluggäste und für die
betroffenen beschäftigten und es geht
nicht nur um die vielen flugverspätungen
und ausstellung viele fluggäste
erreichen ihre flüge erst gar nicht weil
bereits am check in schalter aber vor
allem in der sicherheitskontrolle und
gepäckabfertigung das nötige personal in
dreistelliger höhe fehlt wie auch am
düsseldorfer flughafen in meinem
wahlkreis
nach zwei jahren kroner bedingter
zwangspause wollten und könnten die
menschen wieder fliegen aber warum fehlt
an allen ecken und enden das personal in
flughäfen und bei den fluggesellschaften
obwohl wir hier in deutschland die
arbeitsplatz sichernde kurzarbeit haben
um die unternehmen des kurzarbeitergeld
aufstocken können obwohl die eine oder
andere fluggesellschaft mit richtig viel
steuerzahlergeld in der krise gerettet
wurde haben sich viele beschäftigten
allen warnungen zum trotz gehen lassen
leiharbeiterinnen wurden nicht mehr
eingesetzt befristete verträge liefen
aus viele haben sich was besseres
gesucht und zu ihrem glück muss man
sagen auch gefunden
jetzt kommt es zu den unerträglich
langen schlangen vor den
sicherheitskontrollen
schleppender gepäckabfertigung und
kurzfristig ausgedünnten flugplänen noch
ein weiteres manko hinzu der erstattung
des flugpreises für annullierte flüge
und die ausgleichszahlungen bei
verspäteten flügen da die stelle sich
jetzt häufen wird richtig auf dass die
fluggäste nur sehr aufwändig kompliziert
und sehr langsam zu ihrem recht kommen
jetzt rufen manche ändert die
fluggastrechte eigentlich wollte diese
anderen der union ja fluggastrechte
stärken jetzt ist es zu einem
weiterentwickeln geschimpft aber es gibt
dank der eu sollten so starkes und
eindeutiges wie das recht der fluggäste
auf entschädigung bei flugausfällen und
verspätungen
es kommt immer auf die distanz des
gebuchten flüge und die dauer der
verspätung beziehungsweise die
annullierung des fluges ein punkt es
kommt nicht auf einzelne umstände an es
muss nichts individuelle geprüft werden
die eu verordnung über die
fluggastrechte ist ja klar und eindeutig
tritt der fall ein muss es eine
pauschalierte zahlung der airline an
alle betroffenen fluggäste leben punkt
aber es kommt oft nicht mehr den
entschädigungen weil das verfahren für
die fluggäste umständlich und
kompliziert ist und es kostet zeit geld
und geduld bis man denn schon voll
bezahlten flugpreis und gegebenenfalls
die entschädigung wieder auf dem konto
hat oder man wird gleich das handtuch
was man eigentlich erst am hotelpool
machen wollte aber seine eh schon
strapazierten nerven nichts weiter
schädigen möchte also wir haben jetzt
kein problem mit fluggastrechten wir
haben ein problem mit ihrer durchsetzung
die muss auf den prüfstand
ich sehe nämlich keinen grund warum der
bestattung und die ausgleichszahlung
nicht automatisiert an alle betroffenen
fluggäste ausgezahlt schon am nächsten
tag auf ihrem konto landen könnten die
airline weiß dass ihr versprochen dass
er flug verspätet war wie sehr er
verspätet war oder ob er operiert wurde
sie weiß um die entfernungskilometer die
airline weiß welcher mensch diesem flug
gebucht hat und eher nein kennt die
kennt kontonummer von dieser dieser flug
bezahlt wurde warum kann die
entschädigung der nicht ohne wenn und
aber schnell aufs konto des fluggastes
kommen
der bundesverkehrsminister muss jetzt
zügig prüfen wieso ein automatisiertes
entschädigungsverfahren funktionieren
kann und dann fluggesellschaften klar
machen dass es hier nicht um bilanz geht
sondern um recht umgesetzt wurden auch
sie sich zu halten haben
bundesverbraucherschutzministerin hat
jeder satz schon klar geäußert dass auch
die praxis der vorkasse auf den
prüfstand muss es kann nicht sein dass
die fluggäste bereits bei der buchung
den vollen ticketpreis bezahlung und so
denn airlines monatelang zinslose
darlehen gewähren aber umgekehrt nur
verständlich wie rückzahlungen der
airlines erzwingen können obwohl sie
ihnen doch zusteht das sollte das motiv
auch der cdu csu fraktion sein es muss
schluss sein wir die sachverhalte taktik
der fluggesellschaften die hoffen dass
die fluggäste ihre rechte nicht kennen
sie nicht durchsetzen können und
entnervt aufgeben wir brauchen die
fluggastrechte in diesem punkt nicht
weiter zu entwickeln die ampel regierung
wird diese rechte der verbraucherinnen
und fluggäste endlich auf augenhöhe mit
den rechten der airlines bringen vielen
dank
viele familien machen
als nächster redner das wort erklärte
jürgen braun fw fraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren liebe
demokratischen parteien und auch liebe
sozialdemokratischen parteien die sind
ja hier besonders zahlreich vertreten
sozialdemokratisch immer nicht wir
stehen vor den trümmern von 16 jahren
merken regierungen die weite teile
unseres vorher blühenden landes
abbruchreif gemacht hat die
infrastruktur an land voller kaputte
brücken und straßen an land das keine
großen flughäfen und bahnhöfe mehr bauen
kann ein land voller region die bei
mobilfunk und internet schlechtere
verbindungen haben als in teilen afrikas
ein land reif für die weitere
deindustrialisierung durch scholz
berbalk habeck und genossen in den
letzten zwei jahren haben die
regierungen in bund und ländern die
zerstörung deutschlands auf die spitze
getrieben jegliches leben wurde von
einem wurde einem virus untergeordnet
jegliche reise wurde dem normalen
deutschen erschwert oder gar verboten
sie liebe kollegen von der union haben
eine mittelschwere grippe zur pandemie
erhoben sie haben den grundstein gelegt
für die verfassungswidrigen
grundrechtseingriff die von der neuen
regierung bloß fortgeführt werden ein
bisschen lauter ein bisschen lauter
durch die personalie mit dem sprechenden
namen lauterbach aber im grunde macht
die neue regierung nichts anderes nichts
anderes als die merkel-regierung und
jetzt wollen sie plötzlich entdeckt
haben dass unter den massnahmen sowohl
fluggesellschaften wie fluggäste
gelitten haben jetzt wollen sie erst
entdeckt haben dass der luftverkehr nun
mal teil der wirtschaft ist und dass die
lieferketten rücksichtslos und
gesinnungs ethisch zerstört haben ja die
moderne wirtschaft lässt sich nicht
einfach ausschalten über wochen monate
jahre und dann plötzlich wieder
einschalten anknipsen wie ein
lichtschalter blitzschnell für licht
sorgt jedenfalls solange nicht die
stromversorgung dauerhaft von einem
kinderbuch autor entschieden wird
natürlich gibt es schon seit jahren
willkür von fluggesellschaft
insbesondere beim quasi monopolisten
lufthansa und seiner stets überforderten
tochtergesellschaft euro rings das liegt
daran dass kein wirklich freier markt
existiert weil verbindungen oft nur von
einer fluggesellschaft angeboten werden
die fehlende konkurrenz führt zu solchen
phänomenen wie sehr plötzlichen
flugabsagen kurz vor abflug es gibt ja
sonst niemand aber im kern baden wir
deutschen jetzt die folgen der
verheerenden corona politik der letzten
beiden jahre aus die regierung hat die
bürger im unklaren gelassen im
ungewissen im ungewissen hat die bürger
daran gehindert eine normale
urlaubsplanung zu machen die regierungen
haben nicht nur die freizügigkeit
eingeschränkt sie haben sogar maßnahmen
wie ausgangssperren verhängt die wir nur
aus kriegszeiten kennen die regierung
hat von peking bezahlt um mario fans
panik papiere schreiben lassen um die
chinesischen corona maßnahmen zu
propagieren und den deutschen angst
einzujagen
und sämtliche kritiker dieser
totalitären maßnahmen hat die regierung
zugleich aufs übelste diffamiert obwohl
der diese woche vorgelegte
evaluationsbericht klar aufzeigt dass
diese kritiker von anfang an recht haben
und was den personalmangel der flughäfen
und airlines anbelangt es ist doch
völlig klar dass sich diese menschen
dass sich diese menschen einer anderen
job suchen wenn die politik in zwei
jahre lang keine möglichkeit geregelt
gibt mögliche regel zu arbeiten was wir
jetzt brauchen ist ein umgehendes ende
der diskussions orgien über die
wiedereinführung von corona maßnahmen
die bürger brauchen sicherheit
die damit die horrorszenarien für den
herbst endgültig endgültig im stamm
landen im schrank vor einem herrn
lauterbach wo sie auch hingehören
vielen dank herr kollege braun ich
widerspreche kurz die aussprache und
komme zurück zu tagesordnungspunkt 27
die zeit für die namentliche abstimmung
ist vorbei ich frage deshalb ist noch
ein mitglied des hauses anwesend dass
seine stimme nicht abgegeben hat
das ist erkennbar nicht der fall
schließlich die abstimmung und bitte die
schriftführung schriftführer mit der
auszählung zu beginnen das ergebnis war
die abstimmung über die verlängerung des
mandates also jetzt sind die urnen
geschlossen und es wird ausgezählt das
ergebnis folgt dann sicherlich gleich
hier in der debatte zu den
fluggastrechten hat jetzt
lukas brenner das waren schon bis 90 die
grünen zum thema zurückzukehren über
fluggastrechte zu sprechen darum geht es
hier
die aktuelle situation am flughafen muss
ich glaube ich nicht mehr beschreiben
wir alle kennen die bilder lange
schlangen flugausfälle der erste
urlaubstag besteht aus frust dann rufen
sie bei ihrem pauschalreiseanbieter an
und dürfen sich nochmal stunden in die
schlangen der airlines stellen weil man
ihnen am telefon sagt dass sie eine
bescheinigung über den flugausfall
brauchen die sie am ende nie bekommen
die frage die die menschen sich dabei
stellen die ich so oft in den letzten
tagen von freunden und familie bekommen
hat ist kriegen wir unser geld wieder
dabei ist die rechtslage doch so
eindeutig die fluggastrechte-verordnung
sagt man muss unterstützen am flughafen
man muss die ticket preise binnen sieben
tagen zurückerstatten
und es gibt pauschalisierte
ausgleichszahlung je nach entfernung die
rechtslage ist also klar und dennoch ist
das problem sein anspruch durchzusetzen
nicht nur dass die menschen teilweise
wochen monate jahre klagen um ihre geld
zurückzubekommen nein eine ganze branche
hat sich in diesem land aufgebaut und
mit 25 prozent provision das geld der
bürgerinnen und bürger zurück zu kämpfen
das können wir nicht hinnehmen diesen
zustand liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
jetzt liegt hier ein antrag der union
vor der das ganze ausbauen will einmal
auf punkt 3a geguckt da wollen sie
prüfen ob eine kurzfristige erstattung
der ticketpreise im digitalen system in
einfachen fällen möglich ist wie bei
union um mal ehrlich zu sein das bleibt
doch hinter der rechtslage zurück die
airlines müssen den sieben tagen
erstatten und da müssen wir hinkommen
und nicht in einfachen fällen sondern in
allen fällen und deswegen fordern wir
als ampelkoalition die automatische
erstattung aller forderungen sowohl der
entschädigung als auch der ticketpreise
sofort und daran arbeiten wir und darum
geht es hier
der zweite punkt und frau kollegin
martens hat das richtig gesagt ist vor
allen dingen auch das recht der vorkasse
wir nehmen hin dass anders als sonst
überall im werkvertragsrecht bürgerinnen
und bürger monate im voraus das geld
bezahlen obwohl das sonst der grundsatz
gilt volle zahlung erst nach voller
leistung und ein weiterer punkt und wir
haben es erwähnt sind natürlich die zu
wenigen jobs die probleme an den
sicherheitsschleusen die probleme an den
flughäfen auch da müssen wir nachsteuern
und wir können nicht über fluggastrechte
reden um auch in die zukunft zu gucken
es gilt auch die alternativen zum
flugverkehr zu stärken nach
zugverbindung schnelle bahnverbindung
wir müssen im reiserecht nach vorne
kommen und
die ampel koalition gegeben das thema
fluggastrechte an es bleibt mir nur noch
zu sagen einen schönen urlaub kommen sie
gut an vielen dank
[Applaus]
lukas brenner war das für die
bündnisgrünen und
thomas lutze jetzt sprecher für
verkehrspolitik der linken hat jetzt das
heute sehr geehrte damen und herren herr
präsident lieber
union
in letzter zeit hören wir im haus öfters
dass es sich nun um probleme kümmern und
beheben wollen die sie in ihrer
regierungszeit konsequent ignoriert
haben sogar selbst produziert haben
leider werde ich ihr heute dasselbe horn
blasen müssen dann kamen sie aus der
regierung heraus sind ihnen auf einmal
die fluggastrechte plötzlich wichtig
selbst in der pandemie haben sie es
konsequent geschafft die statisch
bewohner subvention nicht an eine
auflage
ich dachte halt im deutschen bundestag
gibt zumindest maß an niveau aber das
also noch mal von vorn fahren sie nie
haben sie es nicht geschafft die
statischen kroner subventionen an die
auflage zur einhaltung von
fluggastrechten und rückzahlungen zu
knüpfen wie immer haben sie sich als
fels in der brandung gegen jeden
fortschritt profiliert das zeigt sich
auch darin dass die vielkritisierte
vorkasse praxis der fluggesellschaft
nicht beenden wollen aber dazu müssten
sie tatsächlich und die interessen der
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher gehen
und das ist offensichtlich nicht
erfüllen ein weiteres indiz dafür leben
sie eigentlich die treue schwören ist
ihre fünfte forderungen hier fordern sie
dass im rahmen der reform der eu
fluggastrechteverordnung einen ausgleich
zwischen den verbraucherinnen und
verbrauchern und den
luftfahrtunternehmen gefordert wird was
dort aktuell diskutiert wird ist kein
ausgleich sondern dass es ein aufweichen
der entschädigungsansprüche zum nachteil
der fluggäste heute müssen airlines ab
einer dreistündigen verspätung
ausgleichszahlung leisten
nach dem vorschlag der union abhängig
von der flugstrecke werden ist nun fünf
stunden oder mehr das bedeutet konkret
in zahlen 1 3 millionen menschen die
jährlich einen fortschrittlichen
entschädigungsanspruch von 400 euro
haben gehen dann zu 70 prozent leer aus
das macht sich nicht nur im geldbeutel
bemerkbar sondern auch an der reisezeit
die airlines haben dann den mich weniger
anreiz pünktlich zu sein das sind
allerdings nur regelungen wenn das kind
schon im brunnen gefallen ist wir
sollten die ursache der verspätung
bekämpfen und darin liegen und die
liegen in den schlechten
arbeitsbedingungen vor allen dingen beim
bodenpersonal und bei den einsparungen
in den fluggesellschaften begründet
das derzeitige chaos an deutschen
flughäfen lässt sich mit den besten
flugplatz recht nicht kitten hier muss
für meine begriffe angesetzt werden
entschädigungsansprüche sind richtig
aber eine vermeidbarer verspätung
verursacht trotzdem stress und sollte
erst gar nicht passt
gerade die union dass sie heute sofort
abstimmungen forderungen und keine
diskussionen in den zuständigen
ausschüssen wollen deshalb reicht es aus
sicht der linksfraktion beim ich alles
falsch ist lediglich zu einer
kämpferischen mental dunkelblau
vielen dank herr ohne glitzer nächste
rednerin ist kollegin judith skudelny
fdp fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen sind
der antrag der union ist in seiner
zielrichtung vollkommen richtig aber ein
stück weit banal kanal bedeutet im ideen
gehalt recht unbedeutend sie haben
bereits dargelegt was in unserem
koalitionsvertrag
eigentlich schon vereinbart ist eine
bürokratiearme effizienten
verbraucherschutz für fluggäste auf
europäischer ebene so einfach so richtig
und so überflüssig wäre es gewesen uns
zu sagen
viel spannender wirklich viel viel
spannender an der stelle wäre gewesen
warum haben sie eigentlich nichts von
dem was sie vereinbart haben in den
letzten vier jahren ihre regierung
umgesetzt ich darf aus dem
koalitionsvertrag zitieren wie
erleichtern verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher die rechtsdurchsetzung durch
digitalisierung
insbesondere bei smart contract haben
sie grad auf gesagt deshalb werden wir
die entwicklung der automatischen
vertrags entschädigung fordern und
rechtssicher gestalten sie müssen sich
doch fragen was haben sie eigentlich in
den letzten vier jahren versäumt dass
wir das heute nicht haben für tausende
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher wäre
das heute schön gewesen aber
vielleicht ist die umsetzung dieses
vorhabens ja nicht ganz so banal wie ihr
antrag genau so interessant wird
übrigens zu wesen was haben sie
eigentlich während der deutschen
ratspräsidentschaft
2020 gemacht alle ihre vorschläge zielen
auf die europäische ebene und wir wissen
dass dinge dort nicht ganz so einfach
durchzusetzen sind während der
ratspräsidentschaft wäre hierzu
gelegenheit gewesen aber passiert ist
auch auf dieser ebene nichts vielleicht
sind die dicken bretter wie dort zu
bohren sind doch nicht so ganz einfach
und vielleicht ist die problemlage
gerade auf europäischer ebene an der ein
oder anderen stelle eine herausforderung
eine herausforderung die wir übrigens
auf ampel ebene derzeit sehr aktiv
angehen
deswegen hat tschechische
ratspräsidentschaft auch offen darüber
gezeigt wie sie das problem das ja auch
ein europaweit ist wahrscheinlich auch
ein weltweites ist aktiv anzugehen das
luftfahrtbundesamt hat ein schreiben an
die deutschen fluggesellschaften gemacht
wo sie um umfassende auskunft bitten und
sie anhalten das bestehende recht
einzuhalten und auf staatssekretärsebene
gibt es eine koordinierungsrunde die
kurzfristig lösung für die sommerurlaube
sucht so geht man mit verbraucherinnen
und verbraucher um war versucht die
versäumnisse der vergangenheit schnell
aufzuarbeiten
aber die menschen die menschen wollen
keine entschädigung was die menschen
wollen sind sichere pünktliche und
zuverlässige flüge das ist doch das
eigentliche grundproblem über das wir
uns heute unterhalten und bis es gar
nicht so einfach zu lösen und auch daran
liebe union hat die euren beitrag wir
haben zehn prozent weniger kräfte im
technischen betrieben 15 prozent weniger
personal im bereich von service und flug
begleitung das fachkräfteproblem in
deutschland ist das was hier voll
durchschlägt und gegen die lösung habt
ihr euch 16 jahre lang gesperrt ein
modernes zuwanderungsrecht in
deutschland und ein nationaler
aktionsplan für fachkräfte beides dinge
die die ampel koalition jetzt in die
hand nimmt ich kann niemandem
versprechen dass die herausforderungen
die lange zeit liegen gelassen worden
sind in dem halben jahr gelöst sein
werden ich kann ihnen aber versprechen
dass sie in vier jahren gelöst sein
werden dann haben wir unser programm
umgesetzt wir werden mehr fachkräfte
haben die flüge werden wieder pünktlich
laufen und die entschädigung
funktioniert automatisch weil sie auf
europäischer ebene geregelt sind
vielen dank frau kollegin smith wird
endlich gut sie aus fast 30 jährigen 27
und gebe ihnen das ergebnis der
namentlichen abstimmung über die
beschlussempfehlung des auswärtigen
ausschusses zu dem antrag der
bundesregierung fortsetzung des
einsatzes schaffen der deutscher
streitkräfte an der internationalen
sicherheits präsenz im kosovo kfor
drucksachen 20 19 76 und 20 26 7 40
bekannt ab jede stimmkarte in 627 mit ja
haben bestimmt 526 mit nein haben
bestimmt 99 enthaltungen 2 die
beschlussempfehlung ist damit angenommen
wir kehren nun sorgt also damit wird die
bundeswehr ein weiteres jahr weil der kv
truppe dienen können bis zu 400 soldaten
vorgesehen im moment sind 70 soldaten in
pristina
eingesetzt jetzt geht's hier weiter es
geht um fluggastrechte ein antrag der
union und volker ullrich spricht jetzt
für die cdu/csu
herr präsident meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren frau kollegin skudelny
bei allem respekt
der ist oft gespielte fingerzeig auf die
bisherige regierung ersetzt nicht die
eigene verantwortung und
der applaus der kolleginnen und kollegen
der spd
darf nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen dass
die verantwortung bis dezember letzten
jahres bei der bundesministerin
lamprecht lag die in diesem bereich zu
wenig gehandelt hat wenn zwei in ein
finger auf einen anderen gezeigt wird
zeigen vier auf einen selbst zurück der
toric ersetzt nicht handeln
[Applaus]
das problem liegt im augenblick darin
dass die durchsetzung der fluggastrechte
nicht ordnungsgemäß erfüllt wird woran
liegt das das liegt darin dass die
entschädigungs und erstattungsansprüche
der fluggäste
nicht in dem maße von den airlines
bearbeitet wird wie es im gesetz
vorgesehen ist es gibt hunderte ja
tausende beschwerden von verbrauchern
die verzögerungen feststellen oder sich
in langwierige verhandlungen mit den
fluggesellschaften begeben müssen das
ist weder fair noch in ordnung warum
nicht weil zum einen die fluggäste geben
beim kauf eines skript eines eines
tickets quasi den fluggesellschaften
einen kredit in dem sie das geld
vorstrecken und die kontonummern um
alles ist bekannt und dann kann doch
erwartet werden dass wenn der flug
ausfällt in einfach gelagerten fällen
dass dann das geld am nächsten tag
automatisch überwiesen wird so wie auch
das geld vor dem gebuchten flug auf das
konto der fluggesellschaft 1 gegen das
muss im jahr 2022 möglich sein das
fordern wir ein
und damit deutlich wird um welche
dimension es sich hier handelt müssen
die fluggesellschaft noch aufgefordert
werden die anzahl ihrer verspätungen die
anzahl ihrer reklamations fällig die
anzahl der entschädigungen deutlich
transparent sichtbar zu machen weil wir
durch transparenz auch ein mehr an
verbraucherschutz bekommen wollen das
ist ein weiterer wichtiger teil unseres
antrags es handelt sich um europäisches
recht deswegen ist auch die
bundesregierung aufgefordert im
europäischen rat die entsprechenden
rechts änderungen herbeizuführen
da dürfen sie jetzt nicht zögern solid
sie müssen mutig vorangehen und davon
abgesehen
wir brauchen auch eine klare
verantwortung des bundes bei den
schlangen bei den sicherheitskontrollen
bei der bezahlung der menschen die an
den airports arbeiten es ist die
verantwortung der bundesregierung diese
missstände an den airports anzusprechen
aber auch im sinne der reisenden schnell
zu beseitigen herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
die nächste rednerin hier in der debatte
über die fluggäste richter ein antrag
der cdu csu kommt von der spd anja trotz
heftig
[Applaus]
und kollegen die luftfahrt durchlebt
gerade eine der schwersten krisen ihrer
geschichte und genau genommen sind es
eigentlich mehrere krisen die gerade
parallel ablaufen und sich überlappen
wir haben pandemie krieg hohe
kerosinpreise und personalmangel
das alles trifft eine branche die schon
vorher unter großem preisdruck gestanden
hat bei dieser ausgangslage kann es
nicht überraschen wie schwer belastet
der flugbetrieb seit zwei jahren ist
zu beginn der pandemie kam es zum
beinahe vollständigen zusammenbruch des
globalen luftverkehrs und einer
stornierungswelle wie wir sie noch nie
hatten die
bundesregierung hat damals schnell
reagiert einerseits die unternehmen
gestützt und andererseits dem
verbraucherschutz hohe priorität
eingeräumt die vom bundestag
beschlossene freiwillige gutscheinlösung
steht dafür exemplarisch
sie sicherte den verbraucherinnen und
verbrauchern einerseits das recht zu
trotz pandemie schnell ihr geld
zurückzuerhalten und schafft
andererseits einen rechtsrahmen dabei
den fluggesellschaften die kurzfristigen
geldabflüsse reduzierte der deutsche und
auch der europäische verbraucherschutz
hat sich in dieser zeit als stark und
krisenfest bewährt
dennoch ist es zutiefst ärgerlich dass
viele passagiere ihr recht auf
entschädigung einklagen mussten die
ursachen liegen weniger in der
rechtlichen situation denn das haben wir
heute schon oft gehört die ist
sonnenklar als bei den unternehmen
selbst der andauernde personalmangel ist
im gegensatz zur pandemie ihm kein
ergebnis höherer gewalt
wir haben gestern bereits über den
personalmangel im flugbetrieb sowohl am
boden als auch in der oft debattiert
über die ursachen des personalmangels
haben wir gestern und auch heute schon
viel gehört
ähnliche probleme gibt es genauso beim
verwaltungspersonal dort haben die
fluggesellschaften ganz stark eingespart
und können nun die serviceleistungen nur
mit inakzeptablen wartezeiten erbringen
die politischen rahmenbedingungen für
eine finanziell gesunde luftfahrt werden
wir sicherstellen denn
wenn die fluggesellschaft dann ihren
teil dazu beitragen und in gute arbeit
und eine gute arbeitsbedingungen
investieren wird den kundinnen und
kunden am meisten geholfen
eins ist klar ein stabiler flugbetrieb
ist der beste verbraucherschutz
vielen dank
[Applaus]
da hat man hat das wort für bündnis 90
die grünen
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen der
demokratischen parteien
zeitenwende dieser begriff wird derzeit
viel genutzt insbesondere in der außen
und sicherheitspolitik
interessanterweise tauchte in letzter
zeit aber auch immer wieder einen
anderen zusammenhängen auf letzte woche
schrieb die leipziger volkszeitung
damit beschrieb sie die situation an den
flughäfen derzeit denn gerade im
flugreiseverkehr setzt derzeit auch ein
umdenken und ein erkennen ein nämlich
das erkennen dass günstiges fliegen zu
dumpingpreisen wie wir es jetzt einige
jahrzehnte hatten dass das zu wenig
personal führt dass das personal was da
ist schlecht bezahlt wird und dass all
das letztlich leider zu einem service
notstand führt dessen folgen wir jetzt
jeden tag erleben die hannoversche
allgemeine zeitung hat sogar schon das
ende der goldenen jahre des luft-
tourismus vorhergesagt und ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen als grüne hoffe ich
durchaus dass sie damit auch ein stück
weit recht hat aber nicht desto trotz
natürlich müssen die fluggäste die als
verbraucherinnen derzeit in den urlaub
fliegen möchten die haben ein recht auf
entschädigung
tausende gebuchte flüge wurden in den
letzten tagen und monaten immer wieder
gestrichen und verschoben und viele
erfahren dass erst am flughafen vor ort
und die entschädigung die dürfen nicht
monate auf sich warten lassen ich finde
es entbehrt nicht einer bitteren ironie
dass gerade die lufthansa die auf kosten
der steuerzahler während der korona
pandemie wirklich milliarden an hilfen
erhalten hat dass die sich jetzt so
schwer tut ihre fluggäste wirklich
unbürokratisch zu entschädigen
gerade bei der lufthansa sind in den
letzten wochen über 3000 flüge
gestrichen worden und es werden täglich
mehr das geht nicht da wird die
lufthansa wirklich ihrer sozialen
verantwortung in dieser in diesem land
nicht gerecht
wir haben uns im koalitionsvertrag
darauf verständigt es würde schon
mehrfach angesprochen dass
entschädigungszahlung natürlich
automatisiert werden müssen und
innerhalb von sieben tagen bei den
menschen wieder ankommen müssen für
wirklich schnelle und pragmatische
verbesserungen hat sich unsere
ministerin steffi lemke außerdem dafür
ausgesprochen die vorkasse bei
flugreisen auf den prüfstand zu stellen
der vzbv fordert wirklich einfache
formulare und buttons auf allen
homepages der fluggesellschaften liebe
union dass beides ist wirklich sinnvoll
und zielführend und kurzfristig
umsetzbar viel kurzfristiger als manche
forderungen die sie hier in ihrem antrag
aufstellen daher hoffe ich dass wir hier
schnell wirklich zu unbürokratischen
verbraucherfreundlichen regelungen bei
zahlung und für schnelle entschädigung
kommen und das nicht mehr bürokratie
aufwand noch geschaffen wird wie sie es
in ihrem antrag vorschlagen vielen dank
wir haben sie man hat das wort für die
cdu/csu-fraktion und
sehr verehrten damen und herren liebe
kollegen die pandemie durch das corona
virus hält noch immer an die
infektionszahlen steigen wir hören es
jeden tag viele branchen haben die
auswirkungen der pandemischen lage einen
letzten zwei jahren bereits stark zu
spüren bekommen
auch vor allem der luftverkehr der 2020
fast vollständig zu martin kam und an
der stelle wo martens und rohheit man
sie haben sie zwei mal angesprochen die
kreditzahlung an die lufthansa wurden
bereits komplett zurückgezahlt das
sollte vielleicht an der stelle auch mal
gesagt werden wenn sie das hier
bemängeln dass die kreditzahlung gezählt
wurden
werden derzeit sind arbeitnehmerhand
arbeitnehmer in kurzarbeit gerutscht
haben teilweise ihren job ganz verloren
oder haben sich beruflich schlicht
umorientiert ganz aktiv gleichzeitig
wurden urlaubsgeld letzten zwei jahre
aufgespart nach der langen zeit des
verzichts wollen die bürgerinnen und
bürger verständlicher weise wieder raus
wollen wir fliegen und in diesem sommer
verreisen und bei flugreisen sehen wir
die auswirkung aktuell besonders heftig
wir haben es auch schon öfter gehört
heute lange schlangen bei den
passagierkontrollen ewige wartezeiten
bei der koffer ausgabe regelmäßige
verspätung aber auch flugausfälle
und so weiter fehlende fachkräfte ein
hoher krankenstand sowohl an flughäfen
auch als bei den airlines sorgen für
dieses jahres das darf aber nicht zu
lasten der passagiere gehen
und das ist was in unserem antrag
fordern sie sollten eigentlich
selbstverständlich sein dass die rechte
von flugreisenden gegenüber
luftfahrtunternehmen immer gewahrt sein
müssen wer eine bezahlte leistung
unverschuldet nicht in anspruch nehmen
kann muss entsprechend entschädigt
werden und das fordern wir in unserem
antrag dass diese eigentlich simplen
selbstverständliche feststellung hier im
deutschen bundestag heute angesprochen
werden muss zeigt doch dass die
bundesregierung schlicht und ergreifend
nicht an der seite der passagiere steht
es reicht eben nicht liebe kollegen
kollegen in der ampelkoalition auf die
vorgängerregierung zu schimpfen die spd
war zwölf jahre beteiligt die fdp war
vier jahre beteiligte letzten vier jahre
hat wer die zuständige ministerin
gestellt die spd jetzt müssen sie selbst
aktiv werden an dieser stelle als
koalition mit diesem antrag unterstützen
wie sie beugt sehr gern und
weil sie bisher eben nicht aktiv
geworden sind sondern hier
ausschließlich blumige versprechen
abgeben fordern wie mit dem vorliegenden
antrag die bundesregierung auf sich
endlich für änderungen vor allem auf
europäischer ebene einzusetzen und tier
wird sehr entschieden wir reden hier
schließlich über luftverkehr das
funktioniert nicht national dass es
zumindest europäische aber auf jeden
fall auch globalen niemandem ist
geholfen wenn verbraucherrechte nicht
explizit europaweit gestärkt werden es
macht keinen sinn in insbesondere die
low cost carrier hier aus der
verantwortung zu lassen da kann man mal
kritiken die deutsche
luftverkehrswirtschaft steht bereits im
starken wettbewerb mit ausländischen
fluggesellschaften gerade durch
nationale einseitig nationale
belastungen die sie ja sogar noch
forcieren thema kerosinsteuer deswegen
darf es keine weiteren
wettbewerbsverzerrungen zu lasten
deutscher airlines und damit der
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer in
unserem land geben
wenn ich mal aus dem koalitionsvertrag
noch profitieren doch bei neuregelungen
der fluggastrechteverordnung setzen wir
uns für den erhalt des bestehenden
schutzniveaus ein ja das ist doch das
was wir hier jetzt auch forderungen
womit wir eben zu handeln dafür wartet
aber führungen seitens der
bundesregierung auf europäischer ebene
die bedauerliche bedauerlicherweise
nicht vorhanden ist deswegen bitten wir
hier zustimmung zu unserem interaktiven
dann
soweit wir simon hier in dieser debatte
zu fluggastrechten die die
unionsfraktion weiter entwickeln möchte
und die letzte rednerin kommt aus der
spd-fraktion luisa licina bruder
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin werte
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
damen und herren die
aktuelle situation an den flughäfen ist
tatsächlich eine zumutung von daher
macht der antrag insoweit sind als wir
mal grundsätzlich auch darüber sprechen
können was sich derzeit abspielt in der
vergangenheit waren sie als cdu csu eben
nicht die treibende kraft was
verbraucherschutz rechte angeht es wurde
schon angebrochen smart connect hätten
wir gerne mit ihnen umgesetzt hat in der
vergangenheit wohl nicht geklappt wurde
mir berichtet ich war ja da noch nicht
hier in diesem deutschen bundestag aber
insgesamt muss man eben sagen das wir ja
genau das was sie gerade sagen es im
koalitionsvertrag auch drin haben und
ganz und ganz weit weg davon sind dass
wir verbraucherschutz nicht umsetzen
wollen ganz im gegenteil wir wollen das
und wir machen müssen deshalb ist ihr
antrag stückweise überflüssig
die fluggäste werden derzeit von den
fluggesellschaften vor vollendete
tatsachen gestellt und schlichtweg in
der situation allein gelassen auch das
ist richtig annulierte flüge stornierte
flüge aber auch nicht erst in der korona
pandemie und eins muss man sagen die
reaktion der fluggesellschaften können
wir natürlich so überhaupt nicht
hinnehmen weder adäquat noch zeigten
dies die fluggäste werden da einfach vor
vollendete tatsachen gestellt
zur eu fluggastrechte linie hat meine
kollegin auch besprochen die bestehende
rechtslage ist klar alle es bestehen
zahlreiche
entschädigungsansprüche der den
fluggästen zu stehen das problem ist
jedoch dass verbraucherinnen in vielen
fällen erst mal den klageweg beschreiten
müssen um diese rechte überhaupt
durchzusetzen wir können jetzt noch mehr
markttransparenz und
fluggesellschaften dinge auflisten
lassen es wird er am ende den
verbraucherinnen nichts bringen und uns
geht's in dem moment auch um die
verbraucherinnen wichtiger ist es dass
ihre rechte durchsetzen und deshalb
möchte ich mal den blick auf was uns auf
ein anderes thema richten nämlich darauf
dass wir verbraucherrechte dadurch
stärken werden dass wir zeitnah dieser
bands planrecht wieder umsetzen werden
das ist nämlich eu-recht und da werden
ja demnächst verbraucherinnen und
fluggäste die eben auch verbraucher sind
ermächtigen dass sie sich mit
fluggesellschaften auf augenhöhe
unterhalten
sie müssen sich nicht mehr fragen kann
ich mir das leisten die rechte
einzuklagen wie mache ich das überhaupt
wir werden verbände beispielsweise
verbraucherschutzzentralen für die
werden dann quasi für die fluggäste die
ansprüche einklagen können das ist ein
thema was ihn sicherlich auch nicht
gefällt weil das ja auch nicht unbedingt
ihre klientel ist aber am ende ist es
das was eu recht an verbraucherschutz
bringen wird und was wird derzeit auf eu
ebene auch umsetzen
eines gastwirts stellte bei einer
aktuellen situation noch eine ganz
andere frage die eben noch nicht
angesprochen wurde doch wir haben uns da
auch in der spd-fraktion auch schon
länger ich sage mal positioniert und wir
sprechen dieses thema auch an die
sicherheitskontrollen und die
abfertigung an unseren deutschen
flughäfen werden nämlich von privaten
unternehmen betrieben die naturgemäß
gewinnorientiert arbeiten das ist auch
das problem warum auch die vielen
arbeitnehmerinnen aber beschäftigten in
den flughäfen in der pandemie verloren
ging und warum wir jetzt dieses dilemma
haben und wir müssen jetzt konsequent
auch darüber nachdenkt wie mit den
flugbetrieb wird zukunftsfest aus
gestalten wollen und wenn wir das wollen
dann müssen wir vielleicht auch mal
darauf manipulieren schafft müssten zum
ende kommen bitte nachricht die
gewerkschaften fordern nämlich dass wir
das alles wieder in staatlicher hand
damit stabilität gewährleisten und den
flugbetrieb zukunftsfest machen und das
wäre doch ein anderer aspekt vielen dank
[Applaus]